Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Önsuvalı. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenant tätig.
Ich würde gerne heute mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Am Anfang benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten, dann können wir weiterführen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Hane Lore Pfeiffer.
Hane Lore Pfeiffer.
Ok. Bitte könnten Sie Ihre Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Gerne Herr Doktor. Mein Vorname, Hane Lore Pfeiffer, ist H wie Heinrich, A wie Anton, N wie Nordpol, E wie Emil, L wie Ludwig, O wie Otto, R wie Richard und am Ende E wie Emil.
Und Vornamen, H wie Paula, F wie Friedrich, E wie Emil, I wie Ida, Doppel F wie Friedrich und E wie Emil, am Ende R wie Richard.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Nachnamen wieder langsam buchstabieren?
P, F, E, I, Doppel F, E, L.
Frau Pfeiffer.
Pfeiffer, ja.
Frau Pfeiffer, vielen Dank.
Frau Pfeiffer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt Herr Doktor.
70 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 16. November. 56.
November. 56.
Ja, 16. November. 56.
Ok.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege etwa 75 Kilo.
75 Kilo? Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 75 groß.
75. Ok.
Frau Pfeiffer, was für Sie zu uns heute? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit etwa zwei Wochen Bauchschmerzen.
Zwei Wochen Bauchschmerzen?
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen? Welchen Raum?
Hier, im Unterbauch. Eher links.
Linkseitige Unterbauchschmerzen.
Ja, genau.
Ok, ich habe das notiert.
Frau Pfeiffer, würden Sie mir bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sie sind erdrückend, Herr Doktor.
Oder brennend, dunkel oder kolikartig.
Drücken.
Frau Pfeiffer, wann treten Sie Schmerzen? Bei Berastung oder in Ruhe?
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran, aber vor ungefähr zwei Wochen haben Sie langsam angefangen.
Sie sind im Verlauf Schlimmer geworden.
Langsam angefangen und dann Schlimmer geworden.
Frau Pfeiffer, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Weil von 0 bis 10 0 leichte Schmerzen und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen sind. Wie beschreiben Sie das?
Herr Doktor, vielleicht so 5 bis 6.
5 bis 6. Ok. Brauchen Sie momentan eine Schmerzmittel oder? Wie führen Sie sie?
Jetzt brauche ich nicht. Ich kann es aushalten.
Ok. Können Sie noch weiter aushalten.
Gibt es eine Auflösung für die Schmerzen, Frau Pfeiffer?
Auflösung habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Gibt es etwas, das Schmerzen versteckt oder lindert?
Nach Fetigemessen wird es schlimmer, Herr Doktor.
Nach Fetigemessen.
Verstehe. Gibt es eine linderte Faktor?
Wenn ich sitze, wird es besser. Etwas besser, ja.
Frau Pfeiffer, gibt es noch etwas gleichzeitig? Haben Sie etwas bemerkt? Andere Beschwerden? Zum Beispiel gleichzeitig Fieber?
Ja, ja. Seit gestern habe ich auch Fieber. Ich habe gemessen. Gestern Abend war es 38,4 Grad.
Seit gestern Fieber. Haben Sie noch Stülfrost oder Katschweiß oder?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt. Aber Herr Doktor, seit gestern musste ich mehr als 10 Mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Viel mehr als 10 Mal?
Ja, mehr als 10 Mal. Ich muss häufig Wasser lassen, Herr Doktor.
Ich höre mich eine Brennung beim Wasser lassen, Herr Doktor.
Brennung beim Wasser lassen. Und seit gestern haben Sie Fieber. Haben Sie schon das Fieber gemessen oder?
Ja, wie gesagt, habe ich es gemessen. Es war 38,4 Grad. Im Unterarm habe ich gemessen.
Ja, im Unterarm. Jetzt fühlen Sie sich wie Fieber, oder?
Ja, ja.
Seit gestern ca. 10 Mal?
Heute Morgen habe ich dagegen, oder gegen Schmerzen, ein Paracetamol eingenommen. Nach Paracetamol hat mein Fieber ein bisschen gesunken.
Paracetamol hat geholfen.
Aber nicht für Schmerzen, sondern für Fieber.
Ok, verstehe. Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Herr Doktor, mein Stuhlgang ist nicht so regelmäßig. Ich habe seit etwa 2 Jahren Durchfall und Verstopfung im Wechsel.
Wie war heute beim Stuhlgang? Verstopfung oder Durchfall? Was haben Sie?
Ja, in den letzten 3 Tagen habe ich Durchfall.
Lässt du die Nutzung?
Ja. Und ich denke, es sieht ein bisschen komisch aus. Er ist hellrot.
Beim Stuhlgang haben Sie hellrot gemerkt.
Ja, hellrot.
Seit wann haben Sie das gemerkt?
Seit 2 Tagen, wie gesagt.
Letzteres war heute Morgen. Es gab auch heute Morgen hellrotes Blut. Vielleicht. Ich denke, es blüht.
Ja, ich verstehe. Ich habe das nur gesehen. Seit 2 Tagen haben Sie beim Stuhlgang hellrot gemerkt.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie in den letzten 3 Tagen ca. 10 Mal auf die Toilette gegangen sind.
Aber für Wasser lassen.
Für die Wasser lassen. Und seit 2 Tagen haben Sie beim Stuhlgang hellrot gemerkt.
Alles gut. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich habe kaum Hunger, Herr Doktor.
Kein Appetit mehr. Seit gestern oder 2 Tagen?
Seit 2 Tagen.
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie ab oder zu genommen, Frau Pfeiffer?
Das habe ich nicht gemacht, Herr Doktor.
Keine Gewichtveränderung.
Frau Pfeiffer, leiden Sie an irgendwelchen Krankheiten?
Welche? Was für Krankheiten?
Eine chronische Erkrankung zum Beispiel, eine Zuckerkrankung mit Arterie, Zypertonie oder so.
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich habe seit etwa 15 Jahren Bluthochbrut.
Seit 5 Jahren habe ich erhöhte Blutwertwerte und Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Seit 5 Jahren erhöhte Blutwerte und Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Ok, ich habe das notiert.
Seit wann haben Sie Arterie, Zypertonie? Was haben Sie gesagt? 2 Jahre?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich habe seit etwa 15 Jahren Bluthochbrut.
15 Jahre?
Danke für die Information.
Herr Doktor, ich habe öfter Blasenentzündungen.
Ja, haben Sie schon gesagt, in der letzten Zeit, tagsüber gehen Sie etwa 10 Mal?
Nein, tagsüber. Seit gestern aber musste ich mehr als 10 Mal auf die Toilette zum Wasser lassen gehen.
Und ich sage, ich habe öfter als sonst Blasenentzündungen, früher zum Beispiel.
Ok.
Öfter Blasenentzündungen.
Haben Sie wegen dieser Beschwerde Ihren Hausarzt besucht?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich nehme dagegen immer Antibiotika.
Bei den Blasenentzündungen meine ich nicht aktuell, nehme ich Antibiotika.
Aber bei den Blasenentzündungen nehme ich.
Wann war das letzte Mal?
Vor 1,5 Monaten.
1,5 Monate. Ok.
Letztes Mal haben Sie schon vor 1,5 Monaten Antibiotika bekommen.
Ok. Frau Pfeiffer, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Vor etwa 25 Jahren hatte ich eine Gebärmutterentfernung.
Gebärmutterentfernung, ok.
Ich glaube, wegen Myomen. Damals habe ich immer sehr stark geblutet während meiner Periode.
Wegen Blutung? Ja, Gebärmutterentfernung.
Das war komplikationlos oder?
Ja, zum Glück komplikationlos.
Und als ich jung war, hatte ich eine Blindermenthernung.
Und beim Jungen?
Ja, ja. Ich war 18 Jahre alt.
18 Jahre alt, 18 Jahre. Ok.
Frau Pfeiffer, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Was haben Sie?
Nebibolol nehme ich und morgens Ramitril 5 mg.
Nebibolol und Ramitril.
Ramitril 5 mg? Nebibolol?
Ja, ich erinnere mich nicht daran, Herr Doktor.
Ok. Kein Problem. Ich werde mit Ihrem Hausarzt in Verbindung setzen. Kein Problem.
Und abends nehme ich Atorvastatin.
Atorvastatin, wie viel mg?
Auch daran erinnere ich mich nicht.
Ok. Frau Pfeiffer, kein Problem. Haben Sie Allergie?
Ich nehme auch Abführmittel beim Verstoßen, Herr Doktor.
Abführmittel?
Beim Diämen.
Ja, kein Medikament. Ok.
Seit wann haben Sie Abführmittel bekommen?
Wie gesagt, wenn ich Verstoffung habe.
Ja.
Nehme ich. Aber aktuell nicht. Weil ich Durchfall habe.
Sehr oft oder selten?
Wie gesagt, im Wechsel. Durchfall und Verstoffung. Wenn ich Verstoffung habe, nehme ich.
Ok. Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich bin allergisch. Gegen Kupfer.
Kupfer?
Kupfer.
Ein Metall.
Kupfer, ein Metall.
Ich bekomme dann Jukreis und Altausschlag.
Ok. Gibt es noch Unfertiglichkeiten? Haben Sie noch Unfertiglichkeiten gegen etwas?
Ja, Unfertiglichkeiten habe ich auch. Laktosintoleranz. Laktosintoleranz haben Sie?
Ja, ich bekomme Bauchschmerzen und Belehrungen, Herr Doktor.
Ja. Bauchschmerzen und Belehrungen. Ok. Frau Falka, sind Sie schon vorgeimpft oder?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Auch gegen Covid und Pneumokok. Und jedes Jahr werde ich gegen Influenza geimpft.
Ok. Influenza. Frau Falka, in der letzten Zeit...
Gibt es noch... Ja, bitte.
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie noch gereist oder? Nein, Herr Doktor. Ausland oder? Nein.
Frau Falka, sind Sie schon in den Wechseljahren?
Doktor.
Ja, ca. 20 Jahre.
Natürlich.
Ich hachte sehr der Rauch.
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich rauche nicht.
Ich trinke... Ja, vielleicht...
Etwa ein Viertel Wein am Wochenende.
Ok. Frau Falka, gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Es gibt. Mein Vater hatte Darmpolypen.
Darmpolypen?
Ja. Er ist von zehn Jahren an einem Schlaganfall gestorben.
Schlaganfall von zehn Jahren an einem Schlaganfall gestorben. Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat Diabetes, Herr Doktor.
Lebt noch Ihre Mutter? Ja.
Gott sei Dank.
Haben Sie Schwester? Nein.
Frau Falka, sind Sie verheiratet? Ja, Herr Doktor.
Wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, ich lebe mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder? Ich habe zwei Söhne.
Sind Sie gesund? Beide sind glücklich gesund.
Sehr gut.
Frau Pfeife, was machen Sie?
Seit fünf Jahren bin ich Rentnerin.
Vorher bin ich Lehrerin.
Mathe und Deutsch.
Mathe, Lehrer.
Und Deutsch.
Ok, Frau Pfeife.
Ich habe schon meine Kontrolle.
Frau Pfeife, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Habe ich Krebs, Herr Doktor?
Es gibt Blut im Stuhl.
Kann es sein, dass ich Krebs habe?
Frau Pfeife,
Ich gehe davon nicht aus,
ja natürlich, als theoretisch kann es sein, aber
ich gehe davon nicht aus.
Aus meiner Sicht haben Sie eine Darmentzündung.
Ich habe eine Verdacht auf Darmentzündung.
Das klingt ein bisschen leichter als Krebs.
Ja natürlich, aber wir sollen alle Möglichkeiten weiterführen.
Erstens werde ich Ihren Körper untersuchen.
Dann ein paar Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Dann werde ich Bauchdrossschalen,
gegebenenfalls einen CT veranlassen.
Dann können wir weiter derbe springen.
Soll ich da musisch operiert werden?
Sollte sich Ihre Verdachtstheoretik bestätigen?
Aktuell kann ich das nicht genau sagen.
Aber wir müssen ein paar untersuchen, durchführen.
Dann kann ich etwas sagen.
Aktuell kann ich nichts sagen.
Danke Herr Doktor.
Ich warte auf Sie.
Weiter untersuchen.
Auf Wiedersehen Frau Pfeife.
Das war es für heute.
Kling Kling.
Ja hallo, Özil Wode hier.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Müller.
Ich rufe aus dem Labor Frau Riedel.
Frau Riedel hat ein Hämoglobinwert von 5,88 Gramm pro Dessiliter.
Frau Riedel, könnte Sie bitte Ihre Oberarztin diese Werte weiterleiten?
Vielen Dank Frau Müller. Danke für die Information. Auf Wiedersehen.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Herstich willkommen.
Herr Özil Wode.
Guten Tag.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Woher kommen Sie?
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Ca. 3 Jahre lebe ich in Deutschland.
Was haben Sie bisher gemacht in Deutschland?
Bis jetzt habe ich in Deutschland einen Deutschkurs gemacht.
B1, dann B2 und jetzt aktuell.
Die Deutschsprache haben Sie hier erst gelernt?
Ja.
Okay.
Vorher habe ich nichts.
Seit 3 Jahren bin ich hier.
Und aktuell bereite ich mich eine Fachsprachprüfung vor.
Momentan sind Sie in der Prüfung?
Ja.
Und möchte ich wieder als Arzt in Deutschland arbeiten.
Okay. Haben Sie Erfahrung?
Ja. Ich habe seit ca. 10 Jahren.
Ich bin Urologe.
Ich war in der Türkei als Urologe gearbeitet.
Und wenn es möglich ist, möchte ich wieder als Urologe arbeiten.
Okay. Warum sind Sie nach Deutschland gekommen?
Unwillkürlich.
Ganz politisch sollen wir nach Deutschland auswanderen.
Okay. Verstehe.
Ja, das ist nicht einfach.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja. Ich bin verheiratet.
Ist Ihre Frau auf Arzt?
Ja. Meine Frau auf Arzt.
Hat Sie schon eine Fachsprachprüfung bestanden?
Leider noch nicht.
Ich hoffe, im Sommer oder im Jahr warten wir auf einen Termin.
Bei der Ministerpräsidentenregierung.
Okay. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Frau Oberst, bevor ich meine Patienten vorstelle,
möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Gerade habe ich aus dem Labor von Frau Müller einen Anruf bekommen.
Frau Müller hat mir gesagt,
dass unsere Patienten, Frau Ridal,
Hemoglobinwerte 5,88 Gramm pro Dessiliter.
Diese Werte sind deutlich erniedrigt und anämisch entspricht.
Entspricht anämisch?
Ja, entspricht anämisch.
Was sind die normalen Werte für Hemoglobin?
Bei den Frauen zwischen 12 und 16.
Bei Männern 13,5, 17,5.
Was sind die Werte für anämisch?
Anämisch sind die Werte für die Telescheme,
die Blutung, Vitamin B12, Falschzörel,
chronische Erkrankung und Eisenmangel.
Warum sind die Werte für anämisch?
Weil die Werte für die Blutung,
Blutung, Dyspno, Schwinde, und Tachikardie sind.
Wie können Sie die Anämisch behandeln?
Bei schweren Fällen ist die Dosit-Transfusion
unter 7 Gramm pro Dessiliter.
Noch andere Behandlungen sind die Grunderkrankungen
unter Eisen, B12 und Falschzörel.
Was haben Sie noch für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Es geht um eine Frau, Hannelore Pfeiffer.
Sie ist 70 Jahre alt.
Sie ist am 6.11.1956 geboren.
Sie ist 75 Kilo und 1,75 Meter groß.
Sie stellt sich heute wegen sechstlängiger Unterbauchschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen zahlen im mittleren Unterbauch aus.
Eine Auslöserfaktor ist nicht bekannt.
Die Schmerzen verschlechten nach dem Fettigemessen
und bei den Sitzen.
Als Begleitsymptom...
Entschuldigung, hat Sie das erste Mal diese Beschwerde?
Seit wann hat sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit zwei Wochen.
Aber wissen Sie nicht, ob sie früher eine Schmerzen hatte?
Ja.
Okay.
Die Schmerzinstanz liegt bei 5 oder 6 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Als Begleitsymptom wird seit gestern eine dauernde Fieber.
38,3 Rute gemessen.
Seit drei Tagen beim Stuhlgang hat sie eine dauernde Fieber gemessen.
Melena.
Sie ist auch mal in der Käsur gemessen.
Seit zwei Tagen die Beschwerde.
Sie hat seit dem Stuhlgang die Schmerzen gemessen.
Und die Verstopfung?
Sie hat manchmal Verstopfung, manchmal Durchfall.
Momentan?
Seit zwei Tagen beschreibt sie eine Verstopfung.
Seit drei Tagen?
Seit zwei Tagen.
Seit zwei Tagen Verstopfung.
Ich habe Durchfall gehört seit drei Tagen.
Durchfall.
Verstopfung hat es vorher gemacht, jetzt ist es Durchfall.
Okay.
Wann hatte sie letzte Mal Verstopfung?
Wissen Sie?
Ja, ich habe das notiert.
Die erste Beschwerde war Verstopfung.
Dann für Sie, seit zwei Tagen hat sie Verstopfung.
Okay.
Durchfall.
Seit zwei Tagen hat sie, sie klagt über Durchfall.
Und ja.
Bei der Veketativanamnese seit gestern, als Begleitsymptom seit gestern,
hatte sie ca. sieben Mal Wasser lassen gegangen.
Und seit er hat einen Paracetamol eingenommen, das hat geholfen.
Sie hat zehn Mal zum Wasser lassen auf die Toilette.
Sie ist zehn Mal zum Wasser lassen auf die Toilette gegangen.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Wie viele Üren hatten Sie?
Hat sie? Hatte sie?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Sie hat tolle Kühe, aber wir wissen nicht, wie viele Üren sie hat.
Ja, leider die Frage hat mir nicht eingefallen, deswegen habe ich nicht gefragt.
Okay.
Ja, die Prüfung ist sehr, sehr streng.
Deswegen, sie fangen alle, alle Fehler.
Ja, leider die Frage hat mir nicht eingefallen, deswegen habe ich nicht gefragt.
Aber, soll ich die Frage sofort lernen?
Okay, als Vorerkrankung ergaben sie seit 15 Jahren arteriöle Hypertonin,
seit fünf Jahren Hypertcholestinämie und Herzrhythmusstörung.
Als Vorerkrankung ergaben sie seit 24 Jahren Hypertcholestinämie und Herzrhythmusstörung.
Hypertcholestinämie.
Ja, Hypertcholestinämie.
Hypertcholestinämie, die Hypertcholestinämie,
das war eine Opherektomie oder Ovidektomie.
Hysterektomie.
Hysterektomie, ja, Hysterektomie.
Hysterektomie durchgeführt, das war konterkassionlos.
Mit 18. Lebensjahr würde bei ihr eine Appendektomie durchgeführt.
Medikament anamnese ergab sich ein Nebivolol, die Dosierung unbekannt,
Rametler 5 mg, Atheroestatin, die Dosierung unbekannt und ab und zu abfügt mit Tell.
Nebivolol nimmt sie gegen Herzrhythmusstörung oder nur gegen Bluthochdruck?
Wegen Herzrhythmusstörung. Aber ich habe auch diese Frage nicht gefragt.
Rametler gegen Atheroestatin.
Sie hat nur gesagt, dass sie eine Herzrhythmusstörung hat.
Aber welche Herzrhythmusstörung hat sie nicht erwähnt?
Sie nimmt keine Markum oder andere Medikamente ein, ja?
Ja, nur die Patient Nebivolol und Rametpril gesagt gegen Atheroestatin und hat eine Störung.
Sie nimmt eine Herzrhythmusstörung und noch eine Atheroestatin gegen Hypokalästin.
Er hat eine Kupferallergie, reagiert Pyrrhythus und Erden.
Was ist Kupfer?
Leider weiß ich es nicht. Aber die Patientin hat erklärt, was das ist.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, ein Metall ist Kupfer.
Aber ich weiß es nicht. Was ist Kupfer?
Das habe ich erst mal gehört.
In der letzten Zeit nicht gereist und voll geimpft.
Der Nikotinkonsum wurde verleint.
Der Alkoholkonsum wurde am Wochenende 1 Vierterflasche Wein bejaht.
Bei der Familienanamnese hatte der Vater Darmpolypen und wegen einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Die Mutter lebt noch und leidet an Diabetes mellitus.
Bei der sozialen Anamnese sind die Abdeutenden für die Mathe und die Däher.
Die zwei Kinder sind gesund.
Was ist ihre Verdachtskontrolle?
Die Anamnese haben sich auf Divertikale, Divertikalities,
Was ist Divertikalities?
Die Divertikalities sind die Darmkontrolle.
Die Divertikale sind nicht Divertikalities.
Okay, was ist Divertikale?
Divertikale sind...
Was ist das, was ich hier alles ausprobieren kann?
Ich konnte die Noten nicht finden, ich bin nur auf die Telegram-Gruppe im Divertikul-Gesetz.
Das ist ein Problem.
Die Divertikul-Gesetz kann in verschiedenen Formen sein.
Die Divertikul-Gesetz, die Düsseldorf-Gesetz, war sehr einfach.
Deswegen ist es kein Problem, um darüber zu sprechen.
Ich habe mich nicht so oft auf die Klinik-Klima-Kennung beantwortet.
Ich habe mich wirklich auf die Klinik-Kennung beantwortet, aber ich habe mich nicht so oft beantwortet.
Ich habe mich schon mal von den Bekannten von euch verabschiedet.
Es gibt keine Angelegenheit.
Die Divertikul-Gesetz war vor ein paar Wochen in meiner Klasse.
Ich habe noch keine Noten für diese Kennung vorbereitet.
Aber ich glaube, dass die Divertikul-Gesetz nicht für einen Angstvollen Fall ist.
Es gibt viele Fälle in der Düsseldorfe.
Die Fragen der Divertikul-Gesetz sind ähnlich.
Aber ihr müsst ein paar Kennenspuren von der Divertikul-Gesetz wissen.
Was bedeutet die Divertikul-Gesetz?
Ihr müsst ein paar Dinge wissen, die einen an der Anerkennung sind.
Ich frage euch jetzt.
Was bedeutet die Divertikul-Gesetz?
Die Divertikul-Gesetz ist eine Anerkennung der Dichtarmwand.
Okay.
Es gibt eine Divertikulose. Was bedeutet die Divertikulose?
Die Divertikulose ist eine Anerkennung der Dichtarmwand.
Wunderbar. Das bedeutet die Divertikul-Gesetz.
Aber ich sage Divertikulose.
Divertikulose bedeutet, dass die Divertikulose sehr viel ist.
Okay.
Was bedeutet die Divertikulose in diesem Fall?
Die linkseitige Unterbauchschmerzen im Mittelpunkt.
Das ist typisch.
Verstopfung und Öffnungsattacken.
Blut beim Sturmbank.
Die Hämatose bricht Blut.
Und Fieber.
Aktuell. Bei der aktuellen Amnesie Fieber.
Sprechen Sie?
Bei den Parterdarmpolypen.
Okay.
Klagt sie über Gewichtsabnahme oder Apathitveränderungen?
Bei dieser Anamnesie oder allgemein?
Während der Anamnesie haben Sie diese Fragen gestellt?
Ja, ich habe Apathitfragen gestellt.
Aber die Patienten haben gesagt, seit zwei Tagen keine Apathit mehr.
Aber keine Gewichtsveränderungen bemerkt.
In der letzten Zeit.
Die Patienten haben keine Gewichtsveränderungen bemerkt.
Okay, super.
Ich habe den Verdacht auf Divertilosis.
Was ist Ihre oder welche Differentialdiagnose kommen Sie in Frage?
Als Differentialdiagnose kommen Apendicitis und Morbus Crohn in Betracht.
Und ich habe gerade hier gesagt.
Morbus Crohn.
Ja, Morbus Crohn.
Ja, Differentialdiagnose gibt es viele.
Rangart.
Kolonkarsino, Morbus Crohn, Apendicitis, Ovariellpathologie, Overtorsion oder Pilnephritis, Blasenensundung.
Es gibt viele Differentialdiagnose.
Hat Sie Beschwerden über Miksion?
Ja, die Patientin hat Schwere Miksion und Beschwerden.
Warum hat sie?
Kann Divertilitis Miksion und Beschwerden verursachen?
Ja, die Divertilität verursacht einen Fistel.
Das ist möglicherweise eine Kolonwaginal, Kolonwaginal, Kolonal Fistel verursacht werden.
Hat sie einen Fistel wegen Divertilitis?
Ja, das kann sein.
Warum denken Sie daran?
Welche Beschwerden denken Sie daran?
Seit gestern ist die Patientin über zehnmal auf die Toilette gegangen.
Und bei der Vorerkrankunganamnese, was hat sie gesagt?
Vorerkrankunganamnese, Atelierflikoton, Anzugsunstung, öfters, aber nicht noch.
Öfters? Blasenensündung?
Ja, ich habe nicht...
Vielleicht hat sie schon lange seit einige Beschwerden?
Öfter Blasenensündung, aber ich habe keine Schreibung.
Okay. Welche weitere Diagnostik möchten Sie durchführen?
Ich werde als Erstes eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen, dann Blut für Labor abnehmen.
Bei der Labor Nieren und Leberwerte, Anzundungwerte, CAP und Prokrastonik.
Und über den Status und Kultur überprüfen.
Und allen Drücken Bauchdurchführung und Bauchultraschall auch möchte ich durchführen.
Und gegebenenfalls ein CT-Abdomen.
Und jetzt auch noch ein Bauchultraschall?
Bauchultraschall. Und jetzt noch was?
Bauchultraschall.
Habt ihr gesagt, dass ich einen Batmultraschall machen werde?
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich einen Bauchultraschall machen werde.
Und dann geht es um einen CT-Abdomen.
Ich habe auch schon mal gesagt, ob Sie das getan haben.
Und in einer Art akute Phase, bei der akuten Phase, die akute Kolosphopie ist kontrindiziert.
Kontrindiziert.
Und deswegen möchte ich nicht. Schreibe ich nicht.
Wie können Sie die Patienten behandeln?
Als Initialtherapie, auf jeden Fall möchte ich diese Patientestation aufnehmen.
Und dann Pulsigkeit sofort und Elektro-Substanz sofort.
Und Anarchistik und Antibiotik und Anarchistik und Antipiratik und Antispasmaltikum möchte ich geben.
Und dann Lachstekost, Pulsikaternierung und gegebenenfalls Antibiotikum.
Möchten Sie einen Konsul antworten?
Ja, einen allgemeinen Konsul antworten.
Ok. Vielen Dank. Herr Özyübaba.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Danke. Danke Ihnen.
Ich muss dieses Thema wiederholen.
Ja, natürlich. Aber Sie haben es schon gut gemacht.
Obwohl Sie nicht so viele Noten haben.
Ok.
Ich glaube, das war der Herr Ibrahim.
Ich bin hier.
Ich komme in 10 Sekunden.
Herr Özyübaba, wenn Sie noch Noten haben, können Sie es mir geben?
Ok.
Wir haben es nicht. Ich werde die Telegram-Karte ein paar Mal schauen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe noch ein paar Noten von den ersten Personen.
Sie haben einige Fragen zu der Kampfsitzung geschrieben.
Ich glaube, ich habe nur eine Noten von Ihnen.
Herr Ibrahim, bitte.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Akdınar.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten gesehen.
Haben Sie eine kurze Zeit für mich, Frau Berk?
Ja, bitte schön.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich Ihnen noch etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen sagen, dass Frau Pfeiffer eine Hemoglobin von 5,88 Gramm pro Dessiliter hat.
Sind Sie sicher, ob der Name der Patienten Pfeiffer ist?
Pfeiffer? Ja.
Hane, Lore Pfeiffer.
Das ist der Name der Patienten, die an Amnesgeschicht durchgeführt wurden.
Aber Laborwerte hat andere Patienten.
Entschuldigung.
Riedl oder?
Riedl, Entschuldigung.
Das ist ein Hemoglobinwert von 5,88 Gramm Dessiliter.
Dieser Wert ist deutlich niedrig und entspricht einer Anämie.
Jetzt berichtete ich über den Fall meiner Patienten.
Ja.
Es geht um Hane, Lore Pfeiffer.
Sie ist 70 Jahre alt, am 11.11.1956.
Sie ist 1,75 Meter groß.
Die Patienten kommen seit zwei Wochen durch Bauchschmerzen links.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten und haben einen drückenden Charakter.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 bis 6 von 10 auf der NRS.
Die Patienten erwähnen, dass die Schmerzen in der Mitte des Unterbauchs ausstrahlen.
Als verstärkende Faktoren ist es nach fertigen Essen und linderte Faktoren ist beim Sitzen.
Die Patienten erwähnen, dass sie seit gestern Fieber hatten.
Die Temperatur war gestern Abend 38,4 Grad.
Sie hat einen Durchfall der Polylakezüri in der Appetanz.
Die Vegetative an einem Nästhisch ist unaufwendig bis auf chronische Systesis.
Sie hat seit 15 Jahren Arterie-Lipidämie und Herz-Lüftungsstörungen.
Die Medikamentose nimmt unklaradosierung und abformt ein.
Die Operative an einem Nästhisch gibt Hysterik und Appendektomie.
Die Patienten haben Kopfalergien und Laktoseintoleranz mit Bauchschmerzen und Blöden.
Die Medikamentose an einem Nästhisch ist unaufwendig, aber manchmal trinken sie Alkohol.
Sie ist verheiratet und lebt mit ihrem Mann und hat zwei gesunde Sohne.
Sie ist Rentnerin und arbeitet als Deutsche und Mathelehrerin.
Die Familie an einem Nästhisch leidet von einem anderen Polypen.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine Divertigelitis hin.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbilds, Entsondungsparameter, Elektrolyse, Nierenwärter, Leberwärter,
Ürungsstatus, Ürungskultur kontrollieren lassen.
Anschließend werde ich eine Sonographie veranlassen.
Wenn ich diese Sonographie veranlässe, würde ich gerne eine unklarere Klinik befinden.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, planen ich die nächsten Maßnahmen.
Zuerst würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich die Nahrungsabkarenz, die Flußigkeit zu vor, Antibiotika, Analgetika,
eventuell Spasmalotika veranlassen.
Das wars, glaube ich.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Ibrahim, es gab einige grammatische Fehler,
zum Beispiel, der Vater ist jetzt tot, aber er ist nicht polyp.
Oder, sie ist momentan rentnerin,
für ihr hat sie als Lehrerin gearbeitet.
Ich sage das, um die Begegnung zu erlernen.
Ich würde sagen, sie hat seit drei Tagen über Durchfall geklagt.
Normalerweise hat sie seit zwei Jahren zwischen Durchfall und Verstopfung gewechselt.
Dann muss ich auch die Begegnung der Durchfall erklären.
Das ist auch direkt Hematokesia.
Okay, danke dir, Herr Professor.
Es wird etwas schwierig, aber ich hoffe, es wird gut.
Herr Ibrahim, was ist das für eine 3. Forderung?
Ich denke, Sie sind sehr gut.
Herr Ibrahim, ich bin sehr glücklich.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie nicht auf der Suche des Unternehmens verabschieden.
Es wird etwas schwierig, Herr Professor.
Ich danke Ihnen, dass Sie sich auf die Hände gefühlt haben.
Herr Professor, ich möchte Sie letztendlich sagen,
dass es bei den Begleit-Symptomen, Vegetative und Begleit-Symptomen gibt.
Welche Begleit-Symptome?
Ich würde alles, was mit Divertigültem zu tun ist, bei Begleit sagen.
Begleit, Clacti, Uba, Durchfall, Hematokesia, Polakusuri, Fiba, Inapathens.
Ich würde das hier sagen.
Das ist nicht Vegetative, sondern Begleit.
Sturgangs Probleme, Wassalatsen Probleme,
wir haben alle hier gefragt.
Ist Ihnen übel? Haben Sie schon Erbrüchen?
Erbrüchen, übel, du sagst Zeitwand.
Erbrüchen gibt es, wir haben das Erbrüchen.
Also, was es gibt, ich dringere das.
Was bedeutet das?
Ich frage ein paar Fragen, das kann wichtig sein.
Habt ihr Probleme mit Sturgang?
Hier hat der Patient drei Tage Durfall.
Wie oft müssen Sie zum Sturgang tegligen?
Wie oft muss man zum Sturgang tegligen?
Wie sieht ein Sturgang aus?
Wie sieht es aus?
Gibt es Blut im Sturgang?
Das müssen Sie sagen.
Welche Farbe, welche Konsistenz hat der Sturgang?
Wie oft ist er in der Sturgang?
Wie ist die Farbe und die Konsistenz des Sturgangs?
Gibt es Blut im Sturgang?
Das müssen Sie fragen,
ob Sie ein Sturgang Problem haben.
Der Patient hat gesagt,
dass es zwischen Sturgang und Durfall eine Veränderung gibt.
Wenn es so ist,
kann man es in der Veränderung sagen,
ob es zwischen Durfall und Verstopfung gibt.
Wenn es zwischen Durfall und Verstopfung gibt,
kann man es in der Verstopfung sagen,
ob es zwischen Durfall und Verstopfung gibt.
Wenn es zwischen Ursache und Vertikulierung gibt,
kann man es in der Verstopfung sagen,
ob es zwischen Durfall und Verstopfung geht.
Dann big yeah.
Die Wechsel ist für einige Beispiele spezifisch.
Die Divertikule ist spezifisch, der Koloncarcinoma ist spezifisch und der Reizdarm-Syndrom ist spezifisch.
Deswegen denke ich, dass es hier eine Frage gibt.
Dann kommt die Frage von Wasalas.
Du hast von Wasalas gefragt, was ist in Ordnung.
Ich sage, dass er etwas gesagt hat.
Dann solltest du das auch bezeichnen.
Er sagte, dass er sehr oft geht.
Er geht sehr oft, aber wenn es nur wenige Produkte gibt, dann sind wir auf Polyaküze.
Aber wenn es nur wenige Produkte gibt, dann sind wir auf Polyaküze.
Polyaküze sind nur für einige Beispiele spezifisch, wie Diabetes mellitus.
Deswegen müssen wir diese Fragen stellen.
Wie viel Produkte haben sie?
Wie viel sind sie?
Oder mehr als die?
Weniger als die?
Ist es normal? Mehr oder weniger?
Wir fragen diese Fragen.
Dann sagen wir, dass sie nicht mehr sind.
Wasalas ist eine Zung.
Ist sie in Niktur?
Wir fragen diese Fragen.
Wer hat die Farbe?
Oder ist das ein Produkt?
Das kann auch wichtig sein.
Wenn es eine Zung gibt,
dann kann die Farbe der Produkte auch anders sein.
Die Farbe der Produkte.
Wenn du ein Problem hast,
dann drücken wir das Thema.
Das ist das Gastrointestinal System.
Wenn du so ein Problem hast,
dann hast du viele Fragen,
die du in der Gastrointestinal Systeme
beantworten kannst.
Das ist ein Problem.
Du hast in der Gastrointestinal System
ein sehr wichtiges Thema.
Du hast es abgeschrieben.
Du hast eine Zung,
du hast die Farbe,
wir haben sie,
wir haben sie.
Dann fragen wir diese Fragen.
Dann haben wir die Gastrointestinal Systeme.
Das ist der Fros.
Das kann man immer sagen.
Lydans, Fielait, Königsen, Nichkot, Schlaaf.
Aber wie es sich selbst leichter macht.
Apathit, Gewicht, Schlaaf.
Dann Kalb und Lungen, Lydans und Untau.
Bruce Shimarts, Engelgefühl, Herzrasen, Lufnot.
Was haben wir schon gemacht?
Habbechwerde hat die anderen Gasteointestanz-Systeme.
Ich gehe weiter.
Das ist eine 70-jährige Frau.
Aber es gibt noch die Untau-Bau-Schimarts.
Die Gynäkologie-Anamnese kann hier wichtig sein.
Aber Sie können auch fragen.
Ich habe die Gynäkologie-Anamnese und die G.G.T. Anamnese gemeinsam gefragt.
Deswegen frage ich hier.
Ich vermute, dass sie schon in Wechseljahren sind.
Ich habe es schon gesagt.
Wenn eine 70-Jährige die G.G.T. Anamnese sagt,
kann es ein bisschen seltsam werden.
Es gibt keine Verwaltungswürde.
Denn das ist eine Frage, die jeder fragen kann.
Deswegen habe ich das schon gefragt.
Man kann es auch den Wechseljahren-Anamnese fragen.
Man kann es auch den G.G.T. Anamnese fragen.
Aber ich habe es schon gesagt.
Ich vermute, dass sie schon in Wechseljahren sind.
Lass dir die Monatsplîdung elementieren.
Geh in die Regelmäßigsten Hasta.
Ich kann es wenigstens lernen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit gemieceile Auswürfe,
vaginalen Auswürfe oder Schmerzen beim Geschlechtsvägehebertägen,
Wir fragen uns die anderen.
Hier hast du auch das Begriff, dass du das für den Patienten ausüben musst.
Dieser Patient ist bereits ausgebildet.
Du hast eine Operation in der Zeit gelernt,
also eine Gynäkologie-Anamnesie.
So, das war es mit den Fragen.
Bei den Reaktionen,
ist das Vokaldus Erdorf sehr wichtig.
Herr Stümer, ich bin sehr veräubert.
Auswurf oder Ausfluss?
Ausfluss.
Ausfluss, oder?
Ausfluss, Akundfluss.
Okay, Herr Stümer.
Ich habe es falsch gesagt.
Nein, ich habe auch nicht nachgedacht, ob das auch in diesem Sinne genutzt wird.
Nein.
Ausfluss.
Ja.
Ja, wie du gesagt hast,
ist das Vokaldus Erdorf nicht sehr verleuchtet.
Es war nur einmal vor meinem Test.
Aber es ist erst einmal vor meinem Test.
Ich habe es ein paar Mal gehört.
Deswegen habe ich keine Reaktionen von Ihnen gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Herr Stümer, welche Reaktionen habt ihr hier gemacht?
Bei meinen Reaktionen war es so,
dass ich die letzten Fragen nachgebracht habe,
wenn ich komplex war.
Ob ich hier bleiben muss oder ob ich operieren muss.
Ich habe diese Fragen nachgebracht.
Oder habe ich die Kanzler geplant?
Du hast auch die Kanzler gefragt.
Ich habe die Kanzler nachgebracht.
Herr Stümer, die Technologie ist die beste Reaktion.
Es ist nicht nötig.
Wir haben zwei Optionen bei der Kanzlerreaktion.
Wenn wir die Kanzler als Differenzialtonen denken,
wie wir sie vergeben, wenn wir sie nicht denken,
wie wir sie vergeben.
Also, jetzt, in diesen 70 Jahren,
haben wir eine Frau, eine Bauchschaue,
eine Hämatokasie,
eine Schleimhaut.
Und ich denke auch an Klonkarsinom.
Es ist wahrscheinlich ein großer Possible.
Wenn ich hier anstehe,
kann ich das sagen,
aber wenn ich hier bin,
dass ich nicht mehr in der Kanzlerin bin.
Das kann man so sagen.
So ein Patient.
Aber wenn man Krebse nicht mehr denkt,
ist das nicht für diesen Patient sehr gut für eine Kanzlerin.
Denn das ist wahrscheinlich ein sehr guter Patient.
Dann kann man so sagen,
dass ich nicht mehr in der Kanzlerin bin,
weil ich nicht mehr in der Kanzlerin bin.
Aber wenn ich in der Kanzlerin bin,
kann ich das sagen,
dass ich nicht mehr in der Kanzlerin bin.
Aber für diesen Patient würde es besser sein.
Ob es eine Operation ist oder nicht,
das weiß ich nicht genau.
Ich weiß nicht genau,
ob es eine Operation ist.
Aber ich habe keine Sorgen.
Wenn es nötig ist,
haben wir hier eine sehr erfahrene Team.
Das ist so.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau,
ob es eine Operation ist oder nicht.
Ich weiß nicht genau,
Also wir werden
nach der Unterzucht
entscheiden.
Wir werden überprüfen,
ob es eine Operation ist oder nicht.
Ich kann es nicht sagen, dass ich eine Operation brauche,
weil ich keine Medikamente mit der Handlung habe.
Aber ich kann es nicht sagen, weil ich keine Operation brauche.
Was ist dann passiert?
Ich habe eine Handlung.
Ich kann es nicht sagen, dass ich eine Operation brauche,
weil ich keine Medikamente mit der Handlung habe.
Das ist es.
Ich kann es nicht sagen, weil ich keine Medikamente mit der Handlung habe.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich nicht die Handwerk-Infektion schreiben.
Aber normalerweise kannst du das auch schreiben.
Dann ein Paranteis von Divertikulis.
Komplizierte Mit- und Imra-Mendes-Fiskelin.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so komplex.
Du kannst Divertikulitis nennen.
Wenn sie dich fragen, kannst du das mit Komplizierte Divertikulitis schreiben.
Das ist nicht so komplex.
Komplizierte Divertikulitis bedeutet Komplikation.
Das kannst du da erklären.
Ich würde das so machen, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht falsch, so wie du es so machen würdest.
Ich würde das so schreiben.
Das passt nicht so gut.
Als ich 70 Jahre alt war, war das das erste Mal, dass ich Divertikulitis in der Handwerk-Infektion habe.
Man denkt, dass Divertikulitis in der Handwerk-Infektion in der Handwerk-Infektion entsteht.
Aber das passiert normalerweise in der Handwerk-Infektion.
Das ist aber viel besser für mich.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht nötig, hier die Situation zu sagen.
Es muss nicht viel gesagt werden.
Denn Gebamte ist ja ein Infanter.
Wir wissen nicht, ob es ein Infanter ist oder ob es ein Patient ist.
Ich habe es gesagt.
Das ist nicht so wichtig.
Ich habe es von Mio Mectomide gesucht.
Es war sehr viel Blut.
Ja, aber nur Gebamte ist ein Infanter.
Gebamte.
Das kann so sein.
Es kann auch Reisernd-Syndrom sein.
Normalerweise ist es ein Blut.
Das passt nicht.
Aber es gibt einen Wechsel zwischen Dürfal und Fertig-Töpfung.
Das kann so sein.
Die Differentialdiagnose ist so.
Das alles passt nicht.
Ich sage, dass es eine Sistiz-Diffusion gibt.
Aber es gibt auch Blut in der Kaka.
Das stimmt.
Normalerweise passt das auch nicht.
Aber das kann so sein.